yeah welcome to this video plane and
just a really strong opponent here two
Grand Master suna back Hansen from
Sweden Sweden isn't he from his knee
home Denmark this irritates me now
alright so I boo hoo onion and yeah this
is interesting let's see what happens um
this is the part of my book project that
um I haven't even started yet i'm still
on mostly busy on the news oh and um we
have fun really I'm uncommon set up this
is some similar to what was played in
down candidates tournament between a
girl found and raja baath in the first
round maybe it is the exact same
position not not one hundred percent
sure okay i'm trying to heal quickly go
for c6 and d5 using the hack that this
bishop this night night is so not great
on d 2 I can take a place c5 I should
have thought a bit about that hmm now
this was bad okay it's not it's not
fatal but not not what I intended to do
or what I envisioned let's say and to
play didn't want want this structure the
only positive thing is that this f3 move
really doesn't help fight
and how to continue 96 f 4 might be an
idea yeah I'll be six some some stage
now first going to play Bishop d7 and
maybe rook c8 getting b6 in the mix
yeah this is playable it's not done it's
not super terrible but I didn't I didn't
want this kind of structure so should I
go g6 count a four-seam strong or b6 I
need some sort of counter plane
should see a that can take d 4 1st
quindi for knight c6 this was my idea I
hope it is working at least he didn't
refute it instantly okay should i take c
5 with the vision
yeah Roxy 7 SB should be 5 a 9 p-5 and
this is not not nice at all
yeah very shaky position probably it is
it's very bad for me that you really
don't want to play this movement Roxy
795 looks lost okay Quinn takes yeah
otherwise 96 bb5 I can take maybe you
can play it anyway as at the end e5 is
hanging
no oh 96 but this is not winning
material at least why this better of
course at least it's not a like an
instant loss
how do i get come to flame I need to go
need to use the dark square somehow
maybe this one maybe this one winning a
temple to try to I want to play
something like Bishop t6 sent to
something on the dark squares it's not
easy though d force pretty pointless
quincy aid
yeah maybe this one intending Queen III
I know he can play rocky one but at
least then he's not threatening to
invade on the sea foam
now of course you want to repeat but
yeah I have the rukon v6 it have a son
have sex so I can recapture with the
rogue if he decides to take it if it
takes okay yeah it's no surprise that he
didn't maybe Roxy one
yeah what's better but it's not it's not
so entirely easy I want to be should be
six yeah yeah don't want want to
exchange Queens
check
who created the sugar six I think
nice don't time
hi Scott no I take 883 there's no mate
I'm warning let's no meet Jack Jack
White who yeah I don't know how well he
dominated this game but then somehow um
spent too much time could easily been me
on the website at some point recognizing
that ok how am I a lot am I going to
make the time control they all the only
thing that I did it I think I at least I
had the impression that I defended this
rather suddenly but of course why this
much better here and it was all due to
d5 this t5 move which was mistimed I
need to I need to do something else here
it's not it's not like black has a big
trouble I mean it's probably that white
is slightly better but it's not it's not
so serious I can first and prepare all
this with 19 75 g six hours similar
moves not intending to clarify the
situation so quickly in the center and
this just leaves wide was a permanent
EDM with the default default square and
and the pressure yeah I lost a bit of no
fear to allow that yeah Bishop b5 him
the computer gives this I thought it
would be good because um this year if i
take now there's just be five may just a
material down relatively best is
probably to play something like this but
it's just an exchange this was the
easiest time to go and
now is yahwah still better for white to
bishops and and better structure but
it's not like instantly winning yeah and
then he lost the thread turn at the end
with the no time at all it is still
better for white disposition a Quincy
one for example still good good
advantage and this now snow losses yeah
it's a matter of time management i I'm
I'm a victim very often myself of
improper time management and those blitz
games with the comments yeah thanks for
watching